[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
احببتها وطويت صفحتها وكم قرا الذيب صحيفه
وطواها السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
جاءت لفظه الضلال في القران الكريم واللغه
العربيه على اكثر من وجه ومعنى منها
الضلال المشهور بمعنى الذهاب عن طريق الحق
الى طريق الباطل ومنها بمعنى الهلاك
والاضمحلال تقول العرب ضل السمن في الطعام
اذا اضمحل وغاب ويقول تعالى وضل عنهم ما
كانوا يفترون اي غاب واضم حل
الم تسال فتخبرك الديار عن الحي المضلل
اين ساروا اي عن الحي الذي غاب واضمحل ومن
هنا سمت العرب الدفن اظلالا فمن دفن يضل
في التراب وتاكل الارض عظامه ويختلط بها
يقول النابغه فاب مضلوه بعين جليه
وغودر بالجولان حزم ونائل
مضلوه يعني دافنيه ومن ذلك قوله تعالى
وقالوا ائذا ضللنا في الارض ائنا لفي خلق
جديد قال القرطبي اي هلكنا وصرنا ترابا
واصله من قول العرب ضل الماء في اللبن اذا
ذهب والعرب تقول للشيء غلب عليه غيره حتى
خفي فيه
قد ضل
[موسيقى]
قيل لاعرابي ساكتا يلزم الصمت كثيرا ولا
يلج مجالس القوم الا قليلا الا تتحدث مع
القوم حين تغشى مجالسهم فقال ان الحظ
للمرء في اذنه وان الحظ في لسانه لغيره
وكان اعرابي يجالس الشعبي قد اطال الصمت
فسئل عن طول صمته فقال اسمع فاعلم واسكت
فاسلم ومما قاله اكثم ابن صيفي في وصيه
لبنيه وكان جمعهم لذلك
المكثار كحاطب الليل من اكثر اسقط لا
تجيبوا فيما لم تسالوا وكفوا السنتكم فان
مقتل الرجل بين فكيه يتشابه الناس اذا
اقبلوا فاذا ادبروا عرفهم الكيس والاحمق
من منطقهم والاقتصاد في الكلام ابقى
للجمام والجمام والراحه
[موسيقى]
الزي بكسر الزاي هو لباس الانسان وهيئته
ومنظره واما الزي بفتح الزاء فهو الطي
والمنع والتنحيه من زوا يزوي اي طوى ونحا
ومنع
الزوج هو الفرد المزاوج لصاحبه كالرجل
للمراه والمراه للرجل يقال هذا زوجه اي
قرينه اما الاثنان المصطحبان فيقال لهما
زوجان وذلك في كل شيء
[موسيقى]
قال بعض الحكماء من خير ما ظفر به الانسان
اللسان الحسن وفي ترك المراء راحه للبدن
وقيل لقمان اي الناس خير فقال الغني قيل
الغني من المال قال لا ولكن الغني الذي
اذا التمس عنده خير وجد
سمع ابو العباس المبرد بعض الاعراب يقول
لابنه يا بني المسيء ميت وان كان في دار
الدنيا
والمحسن حي وان نقل الى الاخره
قد مات قوم وما ماتت مكارمهم وعاش قوم وهم
في الناس اموات
[موسيقى]
من القصص التي تروى عن ابي جعفر المنصور
انه حين بوي له بالخلافه جاءه المهنئون
فجاء في من جاء رجل من الواعظين يقال له
مقاتل بن سليمان فلما وقعت عليه عين منصور
قال اتى من ينغص علينا فرحتنا ثم انه اراد
ان يباغته فساله قبل ان يتكلم قال يا
مقاتل عظمى فقال مقاتل يا امير المؤمنين
اعضك بما رايت ام بما سمعت قال بل بما
رايت قال يا امير المؤمنين مات عمر بن عبد
العزيز
وخلف احد عشر ولدا وثمانيه عشر دينارا
هذه الدنانير كفن منها بخمسه واشتري له
قبر منها باربعه ووزع الباقي على ابنائه
ثم مات هشام بن عبد الملك
فخلف لكل زوجه من زوجاته الاربع
ثمانين الف دينار فيما عدا الضياع والقصور
يقول مقاتل وانني والله قد رايت في يوم
واحد رجلا من ولد عمر بن عبد العزيز يحمل
على الف فرس في سبيل الله
ورايت رجلا من ولده هشام يسال الناس
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل اسعد ام سعيد فما هي قصه المثل
هذا مثل يضرب في النجاح والخيبه كما يضرب
في العنايه بذي الرحم ويضرب ايضا في
الاستخبار عن الامرين الخير والشر ايهما
وقع وهناك مثل اخر يقول الحديث ذو شجون
يضرب في الحديث يتذكر به غيره ومثل ثالث
يقال سبق السيف العدل يضرب في انقضاء
الامر وعدم الجدوى من اللوم او العتاب
واصل هذه الامثال كلها قصه واحده
وهي انه كان لضبه ابن اد ابن طابخه ابنان
يقال لاحدهما سعد وللاخر سعيد نفرت ابل
لضبه تحت الليل فوجه ولديه في طلبها فتفرق
فوجدها سعد ومضى سعيد في طلبها فلقيه
الحارث ابن كعب وكان على الغلام بردان
فساله الحارث اياهما فابى عليه فقتله واخذ
برديه
وكان والده ما قبل ان تعود الابل اذا امسى
فراى تحت الليل سوادا قال اسعد ام سعيد
فذهب قوله مثلا ثم رجعت الابل وتطاول
الزمان حتى حج ربه هنالك وفى سوق عكاظ
فلقي الحارث ابن كعب وراى عليه البردين
اللذين كذلك لولده سعيد
فعرفهما فقال له هل انت مخبري ما هذان
البردان اللذان عليك
قال بلى لقيت غلاما وهما عليه فسالته
اياهما فابا علي فقتلته واخذت برديه هذين
فقال ربه ابي سيفك هذا قال الحارث نعم
فقال ربه فاعطنيه انظر اليه فاني اظنه
صارما فاعطاه الحارث سيفه فلما اخذه هزه
وقال الحديث ذو شجون ثم ضربه به حتى قتله
فقيل له يا ضبه اف الشهر الحرام فقال سبق
السيف العدل فذهبت اقواله كلها
امثالا يرددها الناس الى يومنا هذا
[موسيقى]
يقولون فلان بقيس يستحق الصدقه والصواب ان
نقول فلان بائس اذا كان مستحقا للصدقه لان
بقيه معناها شجاع وفعله بؤس ويجمع على
بؤساء يقول الله تعالى واخذنا الذين ظلموا
بعذاب بئيس بما كانوا يفسقون اي بعذاب
شديد اما بئس الرجل فهو بائس فمعناه اشتدت
حاجته وجمعه بؤس وبائسون قال تعالى فكلوا
منها واطعموا البائس الفقير
[موسيقى]
من الاسماء التي يستخدمها العرب الان في
بعض اللهجات الدارجه يستخدمونها عندما
يريدون الدلاله على التعجب او الاندهاش
يقولون وي وهي فصيحه من اسماء الافعال عند
العرب معناها اعجب
وتلحقها احيانا كافو الخطاب في كلام العرب
مثل قولي عنتره حين قال ولقد شفى نفسي
وابرا سقمها قيل الفوارس ويك عنكر اقدمي
فاذا دخلت عليها الكاف صارت وياك
وتدخل وي على كان المخففه وتدخل على كان
المشدده كما في قول الله تعالى وي كانه لا
يفلح الكافرون ومعناها الا ترون
ويروي مجاهد ان امراه من العرب قال لها
زوجها اين ابوك فقالت وي كانه وراء هذا
البيت يعني اما ترى انه وراء البيت
[موسيقى]
روي عن الشعبيه انه قال سمعت المغيره بن
شعبه يقول طبعا المغيره بن شعبه هو واحد
من دهات العرب يقول سمعته ويقول ما غلبني
احد قط الا غلاما من بني الحارث بن كعب
وذاك اني خطبت امراه من بني الحارث وعندي
شاب منهم فاصغى الي فقال ايها الامير لا
خير لك فيها فقلت يا ابن اخي وما لها قال
اني رايت رجلا يقبلها قال فبرئت منها
فبلغني ان الفتى الذي حذرني تزوجها فارسلت
اليه فقلت الم تخبرني انك رايت رجلا
يقبلها قال نعم رايت اباها يقبلها
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر عن بيت من الشعر
يبدا
باسمائكم
كل باسمه طبعا بعض الناس مسمي نفس الصندوق
الاسود وبعدين بجيب لك بيت شعر يعني فيه
لا تعرف وين الاسم وبعدين بيطلع اسمه فيصل
بس يعني ما خبرك انه اسمه فيصل فتضيع في
المعمعه على كل حال علي المسعودي يقول علي
انت مسعودي وزهره تنور الف جهراء وجهره
والله لا اعرف يا علي من وين جبت هذا
البيت
لكن حياك الله
محمد بن حمد ال خليفه يقول محمد صفوه البر
ورحمته وبغيت الله من خلق ومن نسم
اللهم صل على محمد
زيد الحسناوي يقول يا زيد وينك قبل عامين
يا زين وين انت يوم الليالي كريمه
[موسيقى]
والله يا زيد انا لست يعني مختصا بالشعر
النبطي ولكن اشعر ان العجز مكسور يعني لو
قلت وين انت ومن الليالي كريمه مثلا اتوقع
الله اعلم اتوقع انه يتزن
وجزيته خيرا يا زيد ليلاس تقول ويوم كظل
الرمح قصرت ظله بليله فلهاني وما كنت
لاهيا
مشاركه من ايناس تقول يجوز ان ينتهي باسمي
وما كنت اعلم والزمان مؤانسي ان النوى
ستنال من ايناس
تقول رائعه الشاعر فؤاد بليبل
وريم ابراهيم تقول ريم على القاع بين
البان والعلم محل سفكدمي بالاشهر الحرم
احسنتم الله اختيار الابيات
ومشاركه من ياسمين عاشوري تقول اذا هو
اهدى الياسمين بكثفه اخذت النجوم الزهر من
راحه البدر
وقد جاءت ببيت اخر هنا بدات حدود الياسمين
وشق الورد اطراف القناه
سامح ابو غسان سامح الحربي يقول سامح اللي
ضيق فجوج الطريق
وزلته حاول تجنب جمرها المحبه تشفع الجرح
الرفيق الجدال انطال قصر عمرها هذه من
النبطيه الدارجه كما تعرفون عبد المعين
يقول معين الدمع لن يبقى معينا فمن اي
المصائب تدمعين
وهاني يقول هنيئا مريئا غير داء مخامر
لعزه من اعراضنا ما استحلت
نكمل معها مشاركاتكم وهذه مشاركه من عمران
يقول لا زال ربعك يا عمران عمران مطرزا
بحرير الزهر الوانا يقول لا يبدا لكن اظنه
يفي بالغرض اظنه بالظاء يا عمران وليست
مضاد
حتى تظن بشكل جيد كريم جرار يقول واني
لجرار لكل كتيبه معوده ان لا يخل بها
النصر جميل
ومشاركه من سافر الغامدي يقول سافر تجد
عوضا عما تفارقه وانصب فان لذيذ العيش في
النصب
ومعاذ يقول معاذ الهوى ما ذقت طارئه النوى
ولا خطرت منك الهموم ببالي
رائعه ابو فراس الحمداني اقول وقد ناحت
بقربي حمامته جميل يا معاذ مشاركه من علي
حاجه عبيد يقول لا يبدا بسم الله لكنه
يتضمنه ليس الا يا علي همام سيفه دون عرضه
مسلول وهذه للمتنبي ومشاركه اخيره من منذر
يقول ابا منذر افنيت فاستبقي بعضنا
حنانيك بعض الشر اهون من بعضه
وبهذه المشاركه اصل معكم الى ختام هذه
المشاركات التي اخترتها من فقره وسم اشكر
لكم هذا التفاعل واذكركم دائما بان تضعوا
اسم تاملات الجزيره
[موسيقى]
هذا رجل بناء مدينه وبعد عقدين من الزمن
اصبحت اكبر مدينه في الدنيا
هذا ابو جعفر المنصور العباره التي تتردد
كثيرا عنه انه المؤسس الحقيقي للدوله
العباسيه وفي الواقع الخليفه العباسيه
الثاني سبقه اخوه السفاح الذي تولى
الخلافه اربع سنوات فقط
كان المنصور فصيحا صاحب فقه وحديث عاش في
صباه وشبابه حياه التواري خوفا من اضطهاد
الامويين لقومه بني العباس الذين كانوا
يطمحون الى الخلافه وقد بس العباسيون
دعاتهم لنقض الخلافه الامويه وكان ابرز
الدعاه ابو مسلم الخرساني وبجيشه الجرار
قضاء ابو مسلم على دوله بني اميه واصبح في
سنوات السفاح الاربع الرجل القوي في
الدوله الوليده
بعد اشهر من تولي المنصور الخلافه تستدعى
ابا مسلم من خراسان استدراجا طلب المنصور
من الحرس ان يتوارى الستائر قال لهم اذا
صفقت بيدي فاخرجوا واقتلوه واخذ يحقق مع
ابي مسلم في صغائر الامور ثم
صفها بيديه فخرج الحرس وقتلوا ابا مسلم
كانت الغدره الاولى الباكره
وخرج عبد الله بن علي عم المنصور في الشام
وطلب الخلافه لنفسه وبعد معارك ومناوشات
طويله انفض الناس عن العم فتوارى في
البصره وطلب من الاديب المشهور ابن المقفع
ان يكتب صيغه امان يقدمها للمنصور ففعل
كتب له صيغه
تكبل المنصوره تكبيلا
فاعطى المنصور عمه الامان لكنه حقد على
ابن المقفع فاوعز الى والي البصره بقتله
فقتل شر قتله
ثم ان المنصور سجن عمه في بيت اساسه من
الملح وبعد حين اجرى الماء على اساس البيت
فسقط وقتل تحت انقاضه الهم والمتمرد جرى
كل هذا والعباسيون يتخذون الكوفه ثم
الانبار قاعده لملكهم وفي سنه
145 للهجره استقر الامر للمنصور فجمع
الفعاله في مكان اختاره بنفسه وبداوا
يبنون بغداد
كان المنصور يشتد على العمال في الحساب
بالدرهم وحتى بالدانق الدانق هو السدس
الدرهم فلقب بالدوانقي في زمن المنصور
بدات حركه الترجمه يقول المؤرخون ان
المنصور امر بترجمه كتب الطب اليونانيه
لانه كان يشكو معدته
كان ممعودا
دامت خلافه المنصور احدى وعشرين سنه وضع
فيها اساسا مكينا لدوله ستعيش خمسه قرون
وتزيد هي الدوله العباسيه
ولا شك في ان المنصور كان سيغتاظ جدا لو
سمع المعاصرين وهم يصفون بغداد بانها
عاصمه الرشيد فبغداد هي المدينه المدوره
التي بناها المنصور بالحجر والدم على نهر
دجله
ولكن بغداد في زمن حفيده الرشيد كانت حقا
عاصمه الدنيا كانت فعلا اكبر مدينه في
العالم اذ بلغ عدد سكانها قرابه المليون
التاريخ لا يحاسب الزعماء اخلاقيا والا
لقسى على عبد الله بن محمد بن علي بن عبد
الله بن العباس عم الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
فهذا هو نسب ابي جعفر المنصور
كان المنصور حازما وواقعيا
[موسيقى]
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي مثلها مثل اي
مكان اخر فيها الكرام الطيبون ولكن فيها
ايضا السفهاء والصعاليك ومما يحز في النفس
وفي الخاطر ان تجد صعلوكا سفيها يتطاول
على كريما من كرام العرب او كريمه من
كرائم العرب والكرام طبعهم التغافل
ولكن يبقى في النفس شيء يخرج احيانا على
شكل
غضبه او قصيده او بعض قصيده
لله در مكارم الاخلاق
يا شيخه البيت الكريم الراقي يا ام من
تفديه احرار الورى تفديه بالارزاق
والاعناق يكفيك من شرف المكانه انكم غوث
الطريق ومهجه الافاق
وبان من ربيت اهل فضيله لا يشتمون الناس
في الاسواق
وبان من علمت من ابنائنا يدعون باسمك
للعلي الباقي
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]